We've all heard that sales is the life-blood
of any business, and great businesses who
have their top-line revenue constantly growing
do these three things better than their competitors do.
Here's what it is.
Step number 1: they have the best finders.
Number 2: they have closers.
Number 3: they have developers.
Let me tell you what each one of their roles
is.
A finder is somebody who knows how to get
an interested buyer, a prospect, a lead, a
customer that wants to buy from you.
They're very good at generating interest.
The closer is somebody who has the top 20
F.A.Q.s of any product being sold.
So they know it, they know how to overcome
that objection, they know how to address that
concern, they know how to make sure the customer
feels comfortable buying the product.
And then you have the developer.
A developer is somebody who goes back to already
existing customers and says, "are you happy
with us?
How else can we be of service?
what else can we do for you? is there any
other thing you need with us?"
All 3 matter because this brings more sales,
this consistently closes, and this keeps an
opening for a new flow of customers wanting
to buy.
Now here's the thing: out of all the three,
do you know which one matters the most?
Out of all the three?
Because a lot of closers say, "I'm the best
closer you know," but they only make $70,000/year.
You know why?
Because they're not the best finders.
Without finders, there are no closers, there
are no developers.
So always look for many finders who know how
to generate new customers for your business.
By the way, if you know a great finder out
there, tag them in the video or share this
with them.